lundi 31 janvier le fc versailles 78
points qui jouera son quart de finale de
coupe de france à l'extérieur face à
bergerac une autre équipe de nationale 2
le tirage au sort à peine effectuée le
staff s'est précipité pour préparer ce
déplacement inédit qui se jouera sur la
pelouse du stade francis rongiéras ca
périgueux ça se prépare vite surtout
parce qu'entre le tirage au sort et et
le jour du match ya très peu de temps
donc il faut vite être être réactif
faire toute la logistique pour pour
l'équipe première déjà pour le
déplacement et puis après essayer de
voir ce qu'il est possible de faire pour
pour nos supporters pour optimiser les
chances de victoire pour l'équipe et ne
pas accumuler de la fatigue le staff
organisée minutieusement le premier
quart de finale de l'histoire du club
départ en train jusqu'à bordeaux et à
bordeaux il y aura un train et un car
qui viendra nous nous récupérer pour
nous emmener jusqu'à périgueux où on a
ou on a réservé l'hôtel
on s'entraînera
s'entraînera sur un terrain voisin le
jour du match le matin du match on
repartira en juste après le match à
bordeaux on dormira avant de reprendre
le train pour rentrer jeudi matin au
total le contingent devrait se composer
d'une trentaine de personnes tout le
staff pas tout l'effectif non
non non ce qu'ils vont être choisis par
par le coach bien sûr et et puis
certains accompagnant on est mais on
n'est pas très nombreux à nous dans la
structure des fêtes du club donc
oui dans ce sera une délégation légère
mais suffisante
du côté des supporters un quart va
partir pour la rencontre ce mercredi 9
février à 9h30 direction périgueux une
victoire de versailles dans le sud-ouest
permettrait de mieux digérer les 14
heures de bus aller-retour qui sont au
programme de ce déplacement